Уряд та Верховна Рада змінюють
деякі правила дорожнього руху в Україні.
Які саме нововведення чекають на водіїв?
Серед головних новацій:
Кабмін має намір обмеженити дозволену швидкість
руху в населених пунктах
з 60-ти до 50-ти кілометрів на годину.
Така максимальна швидкість, як наголошують в МВС,
діє в містах і селах в США та Європі.
Її вважають оптимальною,
адже це скорочує гальмівний шлях до 40-ка метрів.
Тим часом урядовий законопроект, який має погодити парламент,
пропонує зменшити межу толерантності при перевищенні
швидкості з 20 кілометрів на годину до 10-ти.
Штраф за перевищення цієї межі – 340 гривень
Якщо ж водій їхатиме на 50 кілометрів швидше, ніж дозволено,
це буде вдесятеро дорожче – 3400 гривень.
Так само пропонується збільшити штраф
за кермування без прав - до 10 200 грн.
Ця сума подвоюється, якщо у водія забрали права,
а він все одно сів за кермо.
І зростає учетверо - якщо він зробив це повторно.
Крім того, посилюється покарання за втечу з місця ДТП.
Водій має сплатити за це 3 400 грн
або може втратити права на півроку.
Тоді як нині покарання за таке порушення
255 гривень штрафу або громадські роботи.
Автори закону також пропонують надати
більше повноважень поліцейським.
Зокрема, вони зможуть зупиняти авто,
якщо запідозрять, що водій напідпитку або під дією наркотиків.
При цьому водій не може вийти з машини
без дозволу поліцейського і під час спілкування із ним
має покласти руки на кермо.
Крім того, зміниться процедура перевірки водія на алкогольне спяніння.
Якщо сьогодні для цього поліцейському треба
долучати двох свідків, то після ухвалення закону
достатньо буде запису на відеокамеру.
Нові зміни також передбачають запровадження
фото- і відеофіксації порушень правил дорожнього руху.
Та випробувальний термін для водіїв-новачків.
Зокрема, перші права видаватимуть лише на два роки.
І якщо за цей час водій порушив правила менше трьох разів,
посвідчення йому видаватимуть
вже на 30-ть років без повторного іспиту.